Democrats embrace infanticide the attack
on wealth creation continues and we
examine the risks and rewards of
American third parties I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show man a lot
of news to get to today president from
finally hitting on his 2020 strategy
which is exactly what I had suggested it
should be I'll explain in just one
second for those who are wondering thank
you I am doing a little bit better today
and my daughter is doing better as well
so I got a lot of emails on that just
wanted to make that clear and my wife is
a trooper she's doing better as well so
thanks for all of the notes before we
get to the news I first want to talk
about your sleep quality so we talked
about your mattress we talked about you
know how your room is it whether it's
darker bright but the truth is one of
the things you never think about is the
quality of the sheets upon which you
sleep because you think okay I'm just
gonna head down to the local retail
outlet pick up whichever has the highest
thread count that's not how nice sheets
work the way that nice sheets work it
depends on how comfortable the sheets
are are they soft are they breathable
well the best sheets that you can have
are from Bowl and branch Bowl and branch
makes everything from pure 100% organic
cotton from their betting's in their
blankets which means they start out
supersoft they get even softer over time
you can buy directly from them so you
are essentially paying wholesale prices
as well luxury sheets can cost up to a
thousand dollars in the store but Bolen
brand sheets are only a couple of
hundred bucks which isn't expensive for
really really quality sheets that you
are going to be sleeping on every night
of your life everyone who tries Bull and
bran sheets loves them in fact when I
tried them they were so good that I
actually took all my other sheets in my
house and threw them away that's how
good the ball and bran cheats are
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund I don't think you're
gonna want to send them back there's no
risk and no reason not to give them a
try to get you started right now my
listeners can get fifty bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
comm promo code Ben again that's bull
and branch comm promo Club Ben 50 50
bucks off your first set of sheets
that's bol and branch com promo code Ben
go check them out for the best sheets
that you will ever have
alright so the Democrats are now
realizing that they have gone too far
this is the pattern of this week's news
Democrats say crazy things because
they're trying to appeal to their base
and also because they have made a
crucial category error the category
error they have made is that if people
don't like President Trump that means
that people don't like anything
President Trump agrees with so they're
making a category error you know there's
there's a category error that people
make about bad
people where they think okay well this
bad person did X therefore X is bad well
that's not always true right Hitler
owned a dog doesn't mean owning a dog is
bad means Hitler is bad but owning a dog
not bad Donald Trump a lot of people may
not like him but that does not mean that
the American people take the opposite
position on all of the issues he
espouses in fact there's a good case to
be made that trumps positions are
significantly more popular than he is
which is why his approval ratings are
generally higher than his personal
approval ratings well the fact is that
Democrats seem not to be able to grasp
this simple concept and so they continue
to maintain that anything that Trump is
in favor of must be by nature terrible
and they go all the way to the other
logical extreme that is how they end up
saying that we should get rid of all
private health insurance in the company
a senator Kamala Harris said earlier
this week that is why you are seeing
states like New York and Virginia and
Rhode Island now considering the full
legalization of termination of pregnancy
killing of the unborn up two points of
birth now what's funny is that it does
show the differential priorities of the
two parties the differential priorities
of people in the United States if you
listen to folks on the left they think
that the grave threat to humanity lies
in things like global warming so Seth
Meyers last night he was talking about
President Trump and suggesting that
President Trump global warming this is
what was going to get all of us killed
Seth Meyers
ahead of the expected polar vortex this
week President Trump tweeted last night
quote what the hell is going on with
global warming please come back fast we
need you
because once again you're confusing
weather with climate how can I explain
this to you okay let's watch a clip of
you being a decent person I will say
this about Hillary she doesn't quit she
doesn't give up I respect that see that
was weather a quick one-time thing now
this is climate give this code keepers
code and that's what's gonna get us all
killed
okay so the suggestion is the global
warming is gonna get us all killed by
the way I should
sidenote make clear that the media are
terrible when it comes to this
distinction between weather and climate
so every time Republicans point out that
there's been a real cold snap across the
entire Midwest and they say our global
warming then people on the Left
correctly say no no no that's just
weather that's a weather event if you
want to look at trend lines then we can
talk about climate every time it gets
really hot outside or there's a
hurricane then people on the Left go ah
look at this this is evidence of global
warming and then we on the right go no
no no that's weather right we have if
you wanna look at climate look at
climate they don't apply this rule
consistently but the main point here is
that for Seth Meyers what's going to get
all of us killed the grave moral crisis
of our age is that it is going to be a
little warmer outside over the course of
the next hundred years and then that may
sit shift sea levels over the course
again of the next hundred years the way
the left talks about global warming is
the same way that President Trump talks
about the so-called border crisis right
it's a slow-rolling problem that we're
gonna have to deal with folks on the
Left suggest in the same way that
President Trump says it's a national
emergency mobilize the military folks on
the left seem to think about global
warming that it is going to be like the
day after tomorrow then suddenly the
earth is going to heat up radically 20
degrees and there'll be massive tsunamis
whomping all of New York City and Dennis
Quaid and Jake Gyllenhaal will be
running through the wreckage it's just
silliness but in any case the crisis
that Democrats really see is a crisis of
the weather of the climate a crisis that
requires a complete destruction of the
systems of human freedom right the
systems of human freedom of free trade
and free markets and free enterprise all
that stuff has to stop because if we
don't stop that stuff then we are going
to be destroyed by the weather what
folks what folks on the Left refused to
recognize it that the real crisis for
humans tip
has been made by people who do evil
things it is not evil to turn on your
air conditioner it is evil however to
kill the unborn okay that's an evil
thing killing the unborn not a good
thing
crises of the human heart are
significantly more dangerous to other
human beings than weather events that
human beings have had trouble
controlling for literally the entire
history of humanity so the left will put
in ordinate focus on climate change but
they will put no focus on the willful
attempts to legalize the killing of
babies fully formed in the womb who just
have not gone through the birth canal
it's truly an amazing thing the same
folks who will say you know people
aren't people aren't undocumented
they're just people and on one side of
the border they're people on the other
side of the border they're people if
there is a border called the birth canal
there are people on one side and not
people on the other according to the
left the left has the same perspective
about human babies that slave owners
used to have about black folks in the
United States if those black folks were
in Georgia then they were property and
if those black folks were in
Massachusetts then there were people
well borders don't define whether a
person is a person or not that's absurd
okay in the same way and it's disgusting
morally in the same way the vaginal
canal does not define whether a person
is a person or not and yet in Virginia
without any controversy Democrats were
attempting to push a bill that would
have legalized abortion all the way to
point of birth and they were saying this
openly now what's amazing about this is
you we're gonna play a bunch of clips of
Democrats talking about why it's good to
be able to kill a baby fully formed
during dilation remember I've watched my
wife in labor with both of our children
that is a baby you know how I know it's
a baby cuz I watch the baby come out of
her this is not difficult but for folks
on the Left they believe the during
dilation and this is the this is the
position of the Democratic National
Committee this is in the DNC platform it
has been four years I have been
bewildered for legitimately years go
back and listen to all of my old
material for well close to two decades
now I have been bewildered why
Republicans don't simply hold up a
picture of a baby minutes before birth
and say this is what Democrats think it
is okay to kill because it is obvious
that this has been and is the standing
Democratic position these days which is
sick it's insane
and Kathy Tran who's a state senator in
in state assembly person in the House of
Representatives in Virginia she
full-scale defended that as we talked
about yesterday
to refresh your memory here is what she
said when she specifically asked whether
for mental health reasons not to save
the life of Munter mother but for any
health reason whatsoever for a temporary
convenience issue a mother should be
allowed to ask a doctor to lethally
inject a fully-formed child as it enters
the birth canal
late in the third trimester could a
physician perform an abortion if he
indicated it would impair the mental
health of the of the woman or physical
okay okay I'm talking about the mental
health so I mean through the third
trimester the third trimester goes all
the way up to 40 weeks okay but to the
end of the third trimester I don't think
we have a limit in the bill so where
it's obvious that a woman is about to
give birth she has physical signs of
that she is about to give a birth would
that still be a point at which she could
request an abortion if she was so
certified she's dilating my bill would
allow that yes okay so she says it's
straight out now Kathy Tran is
backtracking she's suggesting she's
being taken out of context we played you
a full clip she answers a specific
question she answers it with yes that is
not my fault that is not your fault that
it's Kathy trans fault and that is the
fault of the Democratic Party that
embraces this position not just in
Virginia in New York in Rhode Island
across the country this is in the DNC
platform again the Democratic National
Committee platform has no limits on
abortion at any time at any time now
it's funny there is a commentator named
Damon linker and he was saying why is
the right picking on this you know if
the right really believes that an
abortion is morally as evil at eight
weeks as it is at birth then why are
they picking on this the reason that
we're picking on this the reason we're
pointing this out is that we do agree on
the right that an abortion at eight
weeks at ten weeks is just as morally
problematic as morally evil as an
abortion at point of birth but what the
left is acknowledging is that they
believe the same thing in Reverse they
believe that it is just as morally
unproblematic to kill a baby that is
fully formed as it is to kill a baby at
eight weeks which blows their entire
argument to smithereens
because their argument has been a baby
is not a baby that's why you can kill it
but now they're looking at a full-grown
baby in the womb and they're drugged no
no that's okay we can kill that too
because it's the same as an eight week
old baby in the womb and so the argument
is not an argument that we're making we
are demonstrating by pointing out the
partial birth abortion insanity of the
left we're pointing out that there are a
lot of folks on the Left who full-scale
acknowledge that an eight week old fetus
in the womb has the same moral value as
a fully grown baby namely none right
folks on the right say an eight week old
baby on the woman eight week old fetus
in the womb has the same moral value as
a fully grown baby therefore you
shouldn't kill it folks on the left are
now saying a fully grown baby has the
same moral value as an eight week eight
week old fetus in the womb
therefore you should kill it it's fully
crazy I mean a couple of weeks ago
there's a big controversy on this show
because I suggested that pro-life people
that pro-life people are not for killing
babies even in circumstances where
killing the baby theoretically would
prevent a future harm and I used the oft
cited Internet example of killing baby
Hitler right with by the way an example
so commonly used on the Internet the Tom
Hanks commented on it in like 2015 it
was an article in The New York Times
about it in 2015
I said pro-life people would not kill
baby Hitler because we don't kill babies
according to the left every baby is
potentially baby Hitler so killing I
mean it's which one of these is morally
more reprehensible it's it's wild okay
and then it gets even worse we're gonna
play for you the clip of Ralph Northam
again because I think it is important to
analyze what he says and whether he is
lying or not about what he said in just
a second first let's talk about you
getting ready for work in the morning
okay I use all products from Dollar
Shave Club the reason is because the
products are fantastic there are two
reasons why you should have Dollar Shave
Club first Dollar Shave Club delivers
everything I need directly to my door
and second they keep me fully stocked on
what I use so I never run out here's how
it works Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to get ready no
matter what you're getting ready for
they've got you covered head to toe for
your hair your skin your face you name
it they've got it and they have a new
program where they automatically keep
you stocked up on the products you use
you determine what you want when you
want it it shows up right at your door
from once a month so once every six
months that's what I do for there amber
lavender body cleanser which is just
delightful I mean it smells great they
have sage and black pepper shampoo also
fantastic smelling when my wife smells
my hair after I shower with DSC so she's
always says that smells fantastic what
are you using it I say
Shave Club because it's true right now
they've got a bunch of starter sets you
can try for just 5 bucks like their oral
care kit after that the restock box
ships regular size products at regular
price so there's nothing to wait for
get your starter set for just 5 bucks
right now at dollarshaveclub.com slash
man that's dollarshaveclub.com slash men
I love my dollar save club products you
will to dollarshaveclub.com slash pen go
check them out
alright so meanwhile is that you've got
the Cathy Tran clip where she fully
explains baby coming out the birth canal
you can kill it fine and well yesterday
we went through the actual legislation
the actual legislation dramatically
weakens the restrictions on late term
abortion in the state of Virginia
there's proposed language in that in
that piece of legislation that said that
there would have to be substantial and
irremediable harm to a woman in order to
justify late term abortion they strip
that language out they said any harm at
all mental or physical would justify a
late term abortion even if it's
temporary okay that removes all
limitations now what the bill does say
is the bill says that the conditions for
late term abortion for legalization of
late term abortion is that there must be
life-saving measures that are available
if the product of the if the product of
the abortion is born alive and if there
is evidence of viability of the of the
fetus so the idea there is that if you
are in the process of an abortion of
baby the baby comes out by accident
while you're trying to kill the baby in
the womb and it comes out and it lives
if there is evidence of viability then
there shall be some sort of life-saving
measures available to take care of the
kids in other words no infanticide you
can't actually kill the kid that's it
that's in the actual bill governor Ralph
Northam of Virginia went even further
yesterday he went even further so
governor nor them he were gonna play his
clip and they were gonna say we're gonna
talk about what he says he said and then
we're gonna talk about what he actually
said and the distinction between the two
so Ralph Northam is the supposedly
moderate governor of Virginia now let me
remind folks that Ralph Northam ran
against it ran against I believe it was
was it Ed Gillespie invert it was Ed
Gillespie in Virginia and there are a
lot of folks who were angry at ed
gillespie because they felt that Ed
Gillespie had been too loosey-goosey
with the alright and they said well vote
for Ralph Northam there are a lot of
folks know he's a moderate he's a
moderate I have long suggested that
cases where there are candidates who are
morally unprecedented Marty there there
are a lot of folks who make the case
that if there's a bad Republican you
should vote for the Democrat you can't
in good conscience vote for people who
do things like this here is Ralph
Northam yesterday and we're gonna play
the full clip cuz he says he's being
taken out of context he asked
specifically about Cathy trans Commons
that you should be able to kill a baby
all the way up to points of birth and
here's Ralph Northam his answer you'll
hear to the questioner from WTOP radio
in Virginia and she was pressed by a
Republican delegate about whether her
bill would permit an abortion even as a
woman is essentially dilating ready to
give birth and she answered that it
would permit an abortion at that stage
of labor
do you support her measure and explain
her answer yeah I'm you know I wasn't
there
Julie and I certainly can't speak for
delegate Tran but I will tell you one
first thing I would say this is why
decisions such as this should be made by
providers physicians and the mothers and
fathers that are involved there are you
know when we talk about third trimester
abortions these are done with the
consent of obviously the the mother with
the consent of the physicians more than
one physician by the way and it's done
in cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a fetus that's
non-viable so in this particular example
if a mother is in labor I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so I think
this was really blown out of proportion
stop it there but he goes on to talk
about why women should be the ones who
make these decisions and no one else
okay now the way that Northam says this
clip is being taken out of context is he
says I'm talking about cases in which a
baby is born with for example an N so op
a--they the babies more that opens skull
for example baby's not going to survive
and so the late term abortion has been
provided because the baby is going to
die anyway and so what we're really
talking
about his end-of-life care the problem
is that the bill doesn't talk about that
right the bill does not talk about what
happens if you give birth to a baby that
is that that has a severe deformity
that's not what the bill is about the
bill was designed to broaden the scope
of abortion also the way that northern
phrases that he uses to independent
clauses he says in cases where there is
a severe deformity in cases where the
baby is non viable now you could read it
as though he is saying that in cases
where the baby is non viable then we
have an end-of-life care discussion
because you know do you have to use
life-saving measures on a baby that is
non viable after it's born that's his
case but that's not what it sounds like
he's saying here right he is talking
about something different he is talking
about because the bill goes beyond that
the bill says you should be able to have
a late term abortion for any reason that
you could possibly want basically that's
what the bill says as long as you get a
doctor to attest that there's a health
issue at all any health issue then you
should be able to abort for any reason
whatsoever
he is conflating that dishonestly with
cases in which there is a severe
abnormality to the point of
non-viability he's conflating that that
is simply not true the vast majority of
late term abortions in the United States
are not performed for reasons of
non-viability of the fetus or to save
the life of the mother according to the
Guttmacher Institute which is a
pro-abortion group is just not true it's
a lie that's being told by Democrats
secondly by conflating the two he is
making an excuse for people who have a
baby accidentally during the process of
an abortion so what would he do with a
baby that is born alive would he treat
it the same way that he is treating a
baby with and set and insula and
Sephiroth a--they sorry the open skull
syndrome what he is he treating it the
exact same way it's pretty unclear from
that clip it's pretty unclear but here's
the bottom line even if you think that
Ralph Northam is taken out of context
he's endorsing a bill that says that a
fully-formed
healthy baby can be killed as long as it
doesn't exit that birth canal it's
pretty amazing stuff and when he says
severe deformity by the way is he
talking about only severe deformities
like he's actually going further than
the bill the bill as I mentioned says
that if the baby is born and is viable
then you have to provide life-saving
care to the baby but what if the baby is
born is viable and has a severe
deformity and he says severe deformity
what if the baby is born without a leg
for example well let's say that the baby
is born with some syndrome that really
affects the face
let's say there's a severe abnormality
the baby's born Down syndrome is he
talking about a eugenics program a
little clarity here would be useful
because I don't know and you don't know
you know why I don't know when you don't
know because it is very obvious that the
Democratic Party across the country does
not value the life of fully formed
babies in the womb so why would we
assume that they suddenly value the
lives of fully formed babies one minute
after birth I don't think that's a fair
assumption Peter Singer by the way
doesn't repair singers a bioethicists -
believe it or not over at Princeton
University and he's made the case that
there is no logical distinction between
before birth and after birth and
therefore you should be able to actually
kill you should be able to engage the
infanticide I think we're about five
minutes away from the Democrats actually
embracing that position when I say maybe
five ten years they're gonna start
actually embracing that position because
that's how radical the Democratic Party
has become bottom line is this read
their own words watch the tape and
decide for yourself but understand that
one thing is obvious and that is their
actual position on abortion it should be
available on demand - point of birth at
the very earliest right that should be
the restriction so all these other lies
that they're telling you about how they
are trying to save the lives of children
or they're trying to care for children
that's a kid and again the reason that
we are bringing this up is because the
left recognizes no distinction between a
nine month old baby in the womb and a
two-day-old embryo they have the same
moral values and left that is the
destruction of the value of human life
at a root level okay in a second I don't
get to Howard Schultz who's just being
hit with every club in the Democratic
Arsenal for the crime of not running as
a Democrat and not paving the way for
the SJW crowd to take over the
Democratic Party in the country we'll
get to that in just a second first I
need to tell you about a brand new
podcast that is just awesome so have you
ever been interested in the existence of
extraterrestrial life I think it's a
fascinating question people who claim to
have had encounters believe what they
saw but what does the evidence actually
show every week the podcast network has
a new podcast called extraterrestrial it
examines these stories with a critical
eye and analyzes possible scientific
explanations and determines what really
may have happened so I am NOT a big
believer in conspiracy theories when it
comes to folks who say that they've seen
extraterrestrials I tend to disbelieve
it so what's great about this show is
that it is a myth-busting show
extraterrestrial takes a deep dive into
both Close Encounters
potential government cover-ups looking
to answer whether or not we are really
alone in the universe you can listen to
the first episode of Extra Terrestrial
on the abduction of Barney and Betty
Hill right now and then they're gonna
have episodes on the Roswell cover-up
and the US Air Force project Bluebook
and a secret committee formed by
President Truman to facilitate recovery
of alien spacecraft called majestic 12
all this stuff is just fascinating and
interesting new episodes come out every
Tuesday search and subscribe to
extraterrestrial wherever you listen to
podcast again that is e ex tra ter re s
T RI yo extraterrestrial or visit
podcast.com slash extraterrestrial to
start listening right now it's fun stuff
it's definitely a nice break from
politics so go give it a listen okay
meanwhile Howard Schultz being clocked
up and down by the left he cannot be
tolerated and he can't be tolerated
because it turns out that his story is
actually a pretty inspiring one Howard
Schultz grew up in the projects and then
he became captain of industry he's the
founder and creator of Starbucks an 84
billion dollar corporation well Schultz
has been ripped for being a billionaire
and it does demonstrate this communist
ik hatred on the left for anyone who
makes it big and happens to be white so
a friend of mine who has been she was on
my she was on my show on Fox News during
the last election cycle Brigitte fantasy
who's not on the right she's a centrist
I think is fair to say Brigitte tweeted
out I don't understand why it is that on
the left people like Howard Schultz are
despised and reviled for their wealth
they're called evil billionaires how
about Oprah Winfrey is she also an evil
billionaire like if you were running
wouldn't it be a rags to riches stories
about how you can make it in America
it's just they don't like Schultz and so
now they're gonna rip on his wealth well
yesterday Schultz cut a video defending
his background and talking about how he
was really the story of the American
dream and we'll talk about why it is
that so many on the Left can't deal with
us I grew up in Brooklyn New York in
Canarsie in federally subsidized housing
the projects when I was seven years old
my father who is a laborer came home and
had a serious accident he was dismissed
from his job we lost our health
insurance I witnessed a fracturing of
the American dream
I started with nothing and I made it in
America because of the aspiration the
magnetism and the spirit of our country
okay this is really bad though he's not
allowed to say this stuff Oh
present the same words will be two out
she's so inspiring she's so inspiring
look at that rags to riches story in
America see the story of America is
about the ability to aspire to something
greater the ability to be born into
poverty and then to make something of
yourself and yes of course there are
people along the way who give you a hand
up there are people along the way who
help you out there are communities that
try to help you but that doesn't change
the fact that America is in fact a land
of opportunity the problem is that
Howard Schultz happens to be a white guy
who's not running as a Democrat that's
all this is he's a white guy who's not
running as a Democrat end of story
because Howard Schultz is a white guy
who is not running as a Democrat this
means that he's very bad and he has
actually been a child of privilege this
is where the intersectional ideology
that suggests that all human experience
can be reduced to group identity
completely falls flat
so for example Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
yesterday when after Howard Chilton
suggested well he's a billionaire you
know how would he know what it's like to
bring himself up from nothing even
though he legitimately brought himself
up from nothing despite that fact Howard
Schultz is is not seen as that because
he is not he was privileged not to be a
member of any of these other victim
groups so if he's not a member of a
victim group it doesn't matter if he
grew up as a victim of circumstance
himself he is not a member of a victim
group that has historically been
victimized in the United States and
therefore he has to be he has to be
other Shultz was born in Schultz to
Jewish by the way he's but again
according to the left
Jews are just other it's another form of
white people according to people on the
Left according people on the Left if
you're a Jew you're no longer a member
of a minority group because Jews are
successful minorities and just like on
the left Asians increasingly are being
seen as quote-unquote white because they
are too successful fiscally economically
and educationally and so they can be
they can be quotient they can be
quarantined out at places like Harvard
University so Schultz is being ripped up
and down for his own background and it's
it is pretty amazing to watch I mean
that that is simply it's simply an
element of how radical the Democratic
Party has become how radical is the
Democratic Party everybody is supposed
to acknowledge their privilege unless
they are the most non privileged group
in the world like for example I
mentioned Alexandra Ocasio
so Alexandra Ocasio Cortez she says that
even she Alex from Bronx even she a
Hispanic woman even she is a privileged
woman why because she isn't a member of
the least privileged group which would
be transgender minority little people or
something here is a OC trying to explain
why she too is privileged because she is
cisgender every single person in this
country can acknowledge some privilege
of some of some type you know I'm a
cisgendered woman I will never know the
trauma of feeling like I'm not born in
the right body and that that is a
privilege that I have no matter how poor
my family was when I was born okay now
what was beautiful about this excuse
making because that's really what it is
this excuse making is that when it
allows is people to simply rip on anyone
who is successful as actually a
beneficiary of privilege rather than a
beneficiary of the ultimate privilege
which was living in a free and open
America Howard Schultz was not a
privileged kid he did have one privilege
he grew up in a two-parent family
apparently and while you two privileges
he grew up in a two-parent family and he
grew up in the freest country in the
history of the world those would be the
two major privilege two privileges the
first privilege he can't control the
second privilege we can all sort of
control and that is the system under
which we live but the problem is for the
left they don't want to acknowledge the
ultimate privilege which is living in a
free and open system like the United
States's system so what they say is that
your other privileges are the reason
you're successful so the reason Howard
Schultz is successful is because he had
privileges being white slash Jewish
right and therefore we can discount his
story of rags to riches whereas for
Oprah Winfrey we can't discount her
story of rags to riches because she
didn't have that privilege that's how
they make the distinction between
billionaires intersectionality allows
you to destroy the accomplishments of
other people based on supposed privilege
that they experienced even if you have
no evidence of them experiencing that
privilege which allows for you to draw a
narrative line however you want to draw
it so
aoc can point to herself as an example
of somebody who pulled herself up by her
bootstraps and then she can point at
Howard Schultz a guy who went from
poorer than AOC to much more successful
than AOC and say well that wasn't him
pulling him up by his bootstraps that
was his privilege in operation this is
how the left uses intersectionality and
social justice warrior
group identity in order to tear down
individuals who succeed and avoid blame
for individuals who make bad decisions
you can it's a get out of jail free card
intersectionality is too often used as a
get-out-of-jail-free card now is there a
argument that people experience life
differently based on the group's of
which they are apart in the absence of
other information may be but once we
know about their individual life you
can't make that case so if you were to
put in front of me
a black woman and say did this person
have a different experience than a white
man in life I would say yeah based on no
other information sure of course
probably okay but once I know who the
person is once we know who the
individual is if you are still using the
group identity instead of your knowledge
about the individual in order to make a
judgement about the individual now
you're operating off of racism and
sexism so if you just put Howard Schultz
next to Oprah Winfrey and said to these
two people have different experiences
you'd say yeah I'm sure they did every
every person has different experiences
but based on their group identities he's
a white male she's a black female
probably they had different life
experiences that's sort of the theory of
intersectionality but once we know
Howard Schultz his personal story
you can't keep claiming that he is a
privileged beneficiary when his story
does not reek of and yet this is
precisely what the left continues to do
in terms of this is why Schultz should
certainly not run inside the Democratic
Party he'd be a nut to do so in a second
I'm going to talk about the continuing
attack on Schultz which I find
fascinating like it's making me like
Schultz more frankly I'll talk about it
in just a second first let's talk about
how you send your packages this year so
you want to make your business more
efficient well I have an easy way to do
it really no time no effort stam's calm
with stamps calm you say five cents off
every first class and up to 40% off
Priority Mail and you don't have to
schlep all your packages down to the
post office and you have a postage meter
so you know exactly how much you should
be spending on postage stamps calm
automatically calculates and prints the
exact amounts of postage you need for
every letter or package you send you'll
never overpay or under pay again stamps
icon brings all of the services of the
US Postal Service directly to your
fingertips buy and print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps Khan makes it really
easy they'll send you a free digital
scale
automatically calculating exact postage
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs
now stamps calm not only saves you money
it saves you an enormous amount of time
which is why we here at the Daily wire
offices use stamps calm right now my
listeners got a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale see for
yourself by over seven hundred thousand
small businesses use stamps calm just go
to stamps calm click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
promo code Shapiro that is stamps calm
promo code Shapiro use that promo code
and you get that special deal of four
week trial plus proof free postage and a
digital scale go check them out right
now at stamps calm okay I have more to
talk about with regard to Howard Shoals
plus some updates on the jussie Smollett
case we'll get to all of that in a
second but first you need to subscribe
go subscribe over its daily where to
come just do it I harass you about it
every day so I'm gonna keep harassing
you unless you do it because once you do
it then you can just ignore this part of
the program if you're not a daily wire
subscriber you are indeed missing out
our next Sunday special guest is none
other than the great Dave Ramsey okay so
you're gonna want to go check that out
okay it is awesome and if you are a
subscriber you and only you can watch
this episode a full day early it's not
the Sunday special becomes the Saturday
special doesn't mean I'm violating
Shabbat by the way we didn't tape it on
Shabbat not only that all upcoming
Sunday special episodes will be
available on Saturday but only if you
are a daily water subscriber so what
exactly are you waiting for we have so
much great stuff behind the paywall an
additional two hours of me live every
day plus the sunday special on Saturdays
what more can I do for you I'm answering
questions during breaks on the show in
the afternoons my goodness I mean the
glories and privileges of being a
subscriber also when you become an
annual subscriber you get this the very
greatest in beverage vessels the leftist
year's hot or cold tumbler go check it
out makes julienne fries it's amazing
okay
also make sure that you subscribe over
YouTube and iTunes you can get all of
our material or at least what we will
allow you to see for free over there you
can go check that out and leave us a
review on iTunes it always helps we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
so the problem that a lot of the folks
have with with Howard Schultz is that
they want to eat they want to pull the
intrasexual card and Howard Schultz but
it doesn't work unless you actually buy
into the intersectional identity
politics of the Democratic Party this is
why Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders Joe
Biden all at a severe disadvantage
inside the Democratic Party they also
understand that if they were to move
outside the Democratic Party they'd end
up in the Green Party Looney Tunes land
of Jill Stein well Howard Schultz is I
think I think he scares the daylights
out of Democrats frankly and I think
that he ought to scare the daylights out
of Democrats you can see how afraid they
are by the way the media are reacting to
Howard Schultz Schultz is pointing out
guys you know the Democrats are moving
toward socialism and it's not gonna be
pretty
a lot of people aren't interested in
this here are schultz saying this on CNN
yesterday if the Democrats are proposing
anything close to a 70% level of income
tax
how many core Democrats are going to be
supportive of a move towards socialism
not very many President Trump will get
reelected okay so that that is a
statement that scares the death out of
the left which wants to embrace as I say
this full-scale hardcore far-left
positioning and Schultz is reminding
them guys just cuz you don't like Trump
doesn't mean that everybody is going to
resonate to your cause the left is going
nuts over this because they want to
provide the stark dichotomy they want
you to have to choose between President
Trump and socialism and they hope that
if you hate president Trump enough
you'll resonate to socialism and
suddenly you're Schultz saying you don't
have to choose Trump and you don't have
to choose socialism I tell is pretty
good to a lot of Americans you know I
know that a lot of Trump supporters who
listen to this show but understand his
popularity ratings are not all that high
right there a lot of folks who are not
going to vote for President Trump in the
next election cycle the possibility that
Schultz carves into that vote by saying
I don't like Trump and also I'm not a
crazy person not an insignificant
possibility listen to the panic from the
media over this I mean let's let's face
this how bad are the Democrats áthis
Howard Schultz as they threatened them
this guy is utterly charisma free he is
his dull as dishwater I mean he really
is
you watch him speaking you're like wow
this really okay I guess nobody's
looking at Howard Chilton going on he
captures my
imagination all he is is a return to
normalcy he feels like warren g harding
in 1920 that was the the warren g
harding campaign slogan in 1920 after
the insanity of the woodrow wilson
administration was returned to normalcy
Howard Schultz should make that his
slogan honestly because he feels like
return to normalcy for a lot of folks
and this is scaring the death out of
Democrats in the media who really want
the aoc wing of the Democratic Party to
be a Senate the Bernie Sanders wing of
the Democratic Party so listen to MSNBC
s Nicole Wallace freaking out just
losing her mind on Steve Schmidt who's
an advisor to Howard Schultz people are
terrified and people are terrified that
you one of the most visible Trump
critics are now behind someone that they
feel like could take away the Democrats
best chance of toppling Donald nobody is
voting the election is okay everybody
listen her she's so scared she says good
here's the solution don't be crazy
you had one job Democrats won and yes
suck at it Jon Favreau who is on the
Obama team he says it's just a it's an
awful thing to do is gonna ruin the
world ruin the world the pod bros
explaining why Howard Schultz is the
scariest person in the world these two
people brokers in Mike Bloomberg on very
different ends of the spectrum are both
thinking yeah we could both run in the
Democratic primary and we'll just see if
if anyone likes our ideas Howard Schultz
thinks that he doesn't have to do that
that he gets to just run on his own as
an independent and do it that way even
if it means hurting the Democratic aunt
and helping to reelect Trump and that's
that's just a awful thing to do it is I
mean it people should be restricted to
running inside the Democratic Party
where we the pod bros can determine
whether they ought to even receive the
votes of the general public I love that
the people who suggest that Donald Trump
is a force against democracy are
suggesting that third party candidates
should now be banned now let's be real
about this a third party candidate is
not a guarantee that Trump wins
reelection it's not even a guarantee
that all of the votes for Howard Schultz
come from the Democratic Party it is
quite possible that he draws away a
bunch of suburban Republicans who would
normally vote for Trump and now they see
Schultz as some sort of moderate Schultz
is relying on apparently some interior
polling data is what Josh crash our over
at National Journal was tweeting
yesterday he says Schultz commissioned
several ballots has over the past few
months and found the
centrist indie polls between 25 low to
low 30s between 25 and low 30s president
Trump consistently at 29 to 30 percent
Elizabeth Warren between 26 and 30
percent in other words the vote splits
exactly three ways with Warren on the
ballot they found that about 24% of
Democrats defected to the generic
centrist independence alternative and
20% of Trump Republicans polling found
that trumps support was strong with
Republicans around 70% now let's be real
about this generic centrist indie option
would lead to a higher percentage than
if any other candidate were named like
Schulz is not gonna draw all of that the
centrist in the option carry about 40
percent of independence on average in
the surveys that Schulz conducted in
reality this probably is probably you
know he probably wins 10 to 15 percent
of the vote but there's no guarantee
that that 10% to 15 percent of the vote
comes universally from folks on the left
it is quite possible that folks in the
Republican Party see somebody like
Schultz as a return to normalcy also
which is presumably why President Trump
was was ripping on uncial to the other
day but what's amazing is that for a
group of people who are fully convinced
that their ideas are so wildly popular
why this is scared of Howard Schultz I'm
not scared of Howard Schultz I'm not I
don't think Republicans should be scared
of Howard Schultz because I don't think
that the Republican platform is loony I
think the Democratic platform is loony I
think the real hole for the Republicans
has never been their platform with
President Trump it's been president
Trump's personal foibles which is why I
think it's very good that President
Trump today started tweeting out what
should be his 2020 campaign it's very
simple it's very simple his 2020
campaign right
his 2020 campaign is what he tweeted out
this morning he tweeted out and I want
to find the exact quote because he
should just keep saying this over and
over Democrats are becoming the party of
late term abortion high taxes open
borders and crime just say that over and
over and over and over that's all shut
up
just say that over and over make this
election into generic Republican versus
kooky Democrat do that maybe then
Republicans will have a shot meanwhile
Democrats are counting on the growth of
this demographically diverse base it's
really kind of fascinating so as we
mentioned intersectionality this this
philosophy that everybody is a
beneficiary of certain types of group
privilege and we can discount their
personal experience on the basis of
their group privilege this has taken
over the demo
party and it's leading them to miss read
the nature of the electorate it's kind
of fascinating so the demographics of
America are clearly changing in in
interesting ways in 2020 there will be
more Hispanic than black voters and
whites are declining to sixty six
percent of the vote
now a lot of folks on the right have
said well this is scary for Republicans
because as the Hispanic vote percentage
increases as minority vote percentage
increases in the United States that's
obviously bad for Republicans not
necessarily true look at Texas where
Republicans continued to win somewhere
between forty and fifty percent of the
Hispanic vote in Texas in California
that number is like ten to twenty
percent maybe so it really depends on
how the party handles the demographic
shift but the Democrats seem to have the
same perspective which is that as
demographics shift everybody will
naturally move to the left this is not
actually true so here is aoc making that
case yesterday suggesting that the real
driving force in the Democratic Party
right now is minorities inside the
Democratic Party this is not actually
the case of color are usually much
further to the left and white liberals
because racism colonialism are we
understand through lived experience in a
way that many don't understand that
these are issues that are part of a cap
or a hyper capitalist framework okay
that is just not true okay when she
suggests that minority groups in the
United States are further left then
white Democrats by statistical data this
is false white Democrats are actually
further left than black Democrats
because the white members of the
Democratic Party have changed right
they're now all college-educated
hipsters who go to coffee shops in
Seattle but that's whose members of the
SJW crowd is universally rich and
universally white that is who the SJW
crowd is a lot of the folks in minority
communities who are on the Left are
actually not by nature particularly left
when it comes to government policy a lot
of them are left because they have a
false perception of Republicans as
racially insensitive and that's why
Democrats run on the intersectionality
stuff as opposed to running on the
Bernie Sanders platform the problem is
the Democrats are now assuming the
support of those groups and that's a
hell of an assumption to make assuming
that all blacks and all Hispanics are
going to vote for you because you have
sufficiently cast Republicans as racist
that's only going to last so long this
is why Bernie's
Bernie Sanders did not do well among
minority groups in the Democratic
primaries in 2016 he didn't Hillary
Clinton overperformed him Hillary
Clinton was not popular among minority
groups in 2008 because they actually had
an intersectional candidate named Barack
Obama on the ballot but in 2016 Hillary
Clinton overperformed with minority
groups when compared to Bernie Sanders
what happened is minority groups why
weren't they further left than the
general electorate in the Democratic
Party as aoc suggests the answer is they
aren't the answer is a lot of Hispanics
in this country are not in fact as left
as mainstream white members of the
Democratic Party who have skewed far to
the left which is why a centrist
candidate who is not perceived in the
way that Donald Trump is perceived could
do some damage to the Democratic Party
all of this is of course I think really
really interesting and frankly I have
always been a fan of the idea there
should be more than two parties in the
country that are viable I know that the
system tends toward two-party dominance
it tends to because it's
first-past-the-post system
it's a majoritarian system that means
that and there's no secondary voting and
there's no proportional representation
that tends toward well-organized
two-party systems but frankly I like the
idea of there being a lot of options on
the ballot I don't think that it's a
problem I think it's a very good thing
and I think the Democrats trying to shut
it down demonstrates they know that
their own agenda is too radical for the
American people I mean how radical is is
the is the agenda of left
I mean they've gone they've gone so far
left that the Rules Committee for the
the rules for the Committee on Natural
Resources in the US House of
Representatives Democrats were trying to
propose that they actually remove from
the from the oath of office so help me
God but they should actually remove that
now it is not mandatory that you say so
help me God but is pro forma the reason
being that pretty much everyone in the
United States even people who aren't
quasi agnostic believe in the existence
of a higher power the United States is a
far more religious country generally
then folks in Europe are Democrats wants
to remove that this agenda you think
that agenda is in line with Catholics
Catholic Hispanics particularly you
think that agenda is in line with a lot
of black folks in the United States a
lot of black church-going folks in the
United States there is an actual
disconnect that Republicans have yet to
exploit between the radical left
socialist policies of people like Bernie
Sanders anti religion anti
family policies of people like Bernie
Sanders pro-abortion policies of people
like Bernie Sanders and religious
communities particularly minority
religious communities may all those
Catholics all those Catholic Hispanics
who are voting Democrat in the state of
California because they have a
perception of the Republican Party
they're still going to church where
they're being preached to every week
about the evils of abortion why
Republicans aren't focusing on that why
they haven't reached out to minority
communities is beyond me especially in
an era where secular white Democrats
rule the roost inside the Democratic
Party in you're seeing the Democrats
like the Democrats have to Bank on
minority candidates in order to
demonstrate sympathy for minorities they
hope will lead to electoral victory but
I'm not sure that if Bernie Sanders is
the candidate or Elizabeth Warren as the
candidate they can count on the kind of
minority support that they are counting
on Hillary Clinton made that mistake in
2016 by the way she thought she was
going to perform the same with
minorities as Barack Obama did and she
didn't she didn't which proves that it
ain't the Democratic platform drawing
minorities really in his personality and
that's why the Democrats have to use
intersectional politics in order to
excise people like Howard Schultz in
order to excise people like Bernie
Sanders and even Elizabeth Warren is why
Kamala Harris has significant advantage
in the primaries it's why if the
Democratic Party superstructure is smart
they want somebody like Kamala Harris
because if they can signal sympathy via
the race of the candidate then they
don't actually have to determine what it
is that a lot of minority voters might
want in terms of policy those minority
voters may be more sympathetic to
Democratic policies than Republican
policies that's certainly possible but
not to the extent that they embrace
Bernie Sanders crazy at a higher rate
than the normal white Democrat does okay
in just second Donna gets you some
things I like and then we will get to
some things that I hate so things that I
like today so my wife and I have jumped
into a new show on Netflix it is called
travelers and it's kind of a fun show
the basic premise of the show is that
sometime in the future hundreds of years
in the future there's been some horrible
environmental disaster caused by an
asteroid hitting the earth and now
they've discovered in the future a way
for people from the future to basically
inhabit the bodies of people in the
present so what they do is they wait
until somebody's about to die so that
they're not actually killing anyone
and then in the moment where they're
about to die because they know the
history they can inhabit the
of those people and try and prevent
future catastrophe this shows fun and
the shows interesting I'm really
enjoying it with my wife here's a little
bit of the trailer about to undo the
errors of our Cindy's to make the earth
whole lost and lost at peril of her own
birth
30 seconds in the future we've developed
the technology to project conscious mind
it's fun it's a fun show and it's and
it's worth the watch and it's like pg-13
maybe so it's it's there's not a lot
there that's super violent or super
terrible so you can watch it with I
would say mid teenagers it would be fair
so the show is is a kick so check that
out ok time for a couple of things that
I hate so thing number one I'm supposed
to speak at Loyola Marymount University
in the next couple of months and Loyola
had put out I guess a statement to young
America's Foundation they wanted a bunch
of questions answered about my politics
whether my politics were acceptable it
became a bit of a national scandal and
then LMU said listen we're not trying to
obstruct Ben from speaking we're gonna
let him speak well this led dr. nina m
Rossano who I guess is a queer studies
professor I believe that's her biography
so she tweeted out ben shapiro espouses
hate speech and is linked to numerous
hate groups okay I challenged her name a
hate group I'm willing to like one not
not numerous like one as an LMU
professor I will be organizing protests
and alerting the media of LMU's decision
to support hate speech which is
completely antithetical to our
university mission and I would note that
I believe Angela Davis spoke there she's
like an actual former wanted terrorist
by the FBI she says you know that's
completely unethical to our university
mission as opposed to it's a Jesuit
school you know as opposed to the
radical left social agenda which is
apparently not antithetical to LMU's
Jesuit mission I guess but now that
would this funny so she says I'm gonna
come and promote hate speech so I
tweeted back well see you there or not
cuz I don't really care and she said
that she wanted to get the word out to
the media well she has like a foul or I
have about two million followers so once
I tweeted that seems like that would
have drawn some media attention well
then she blocked everybody she made her
account private which is so I guess
shouldn't want that much media attention
oh so sad
amazing how people run for cover the
minute that their radicalism is exposed
okay other things that I hate so this
Jesse smaller case just continues to
develop in real-time we still don't know
what happened last night the Chicago PD
put out a picture of two people who had
says they were looking for and it's just
insane I mean the picture is basically
of two randos you can't see their faces
they look like two shapes walking that I
feel like these people may be witnesses
to something and they're just humans
like that's all you can tell from the
picture great what we do know is that
Jesse small at whose original story
you'll recall is that he was walking on
the streets of Chicago at 2:00 a.m. and
he was accosted by two white guys is
what he his people told TMZ he was
accosted by two white guys who tossed a
noose around his neck poured bleach on
him and shouted this is Magga country in
the middle of Chicago at 2:00 a.m. in 60
under windchill and then they broke his
rib supposedly and for some reason the
police were not called to the scene he
walked back into his Lobby past the
doorman was still 40 minutes later
wearing the noose around his neck
apparently there's no tape of the
incident there's tape of him at the
subway leaving the subway and then
there's tape of him entering the lobby
now with the noose around his neck that
he was still wearing and was wearing
when the police arrived his agent I
guess said that they were on the phone
together when this happened so he heard
all of this but then Jesse Smollett says
he would not turn his phone over to the
police and they could even verify that
that is the reality so he refuses to
allow Chicago detectives to access his
phone in order to end a parent
independently verify his managers claim
that he heard the magg a country attack
while they were talking so we will see
whether any of this ends up what exactly
happened here but suffice it to say it
is not ridiculous to have your doubts
about this story the story itself is one
of those stories where for a certain
segment of the population pushing a
particular narrative about Trump
supporters it's too good to be true so
everybody jumps on it but we can wait
for all the facts to come out and then
we can talk about it or we can do what
the media seems to have done and forget
about covering this thing all the way
until it's debunked at which point they
go oh I guess we screwed that one up
so they'll cover the initial accusation
nothing in between and then when if it
is to bunk'd eventually if it turns out
to be a hoax then there will be like a
couple of stories about how oh I guess
then I guess
that's the way all of this works all
righty so we'll be back here a little
bit later in the day and we'll have much
to speak about then we have to live ours
later in the day which is why you should
subscribe go subscribe now at daily wire
you can join us a little bit later
because we'll be here so so should you
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19